[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 11 décembre
bienvenue dans le journal de tv 60 18 26
minutes d'actualité d'actualité locale
tout de suite les titres
le lancement aujourd'hui de ce
dispositif dans le département 26
caméras piétons seront testés par les
pompiers jusqu'en 2022 expérimentation
lancée par le ministère de l'intérieur
pour prévenir les agressions en
constante hausse cette semaine focus sur
les personnalités yvelinoise de l'année
2019 ce soit rencontre avec l'ancien
vice présidente de l'université
versailles saint quentin armel le bras
chopard elle a été la première femme
agrégée de sciences politiques en france
enfin la page municipal 2020 la fin de
cette édition à la verrière le premier
adjoint jean yves les conduira une liste
divers gauche elle sera composée et
d'élus de la majorité fera face
notamment à la maire sortante nelly
duthu et puis à suivre dans ce journal
la présentation d'une action réveille
toi pro est aussi en cette période de
grève contre la réforme des retraites et
les prévisions trafic dans les
transports en commun pour la journée de
demain jeudi
[Musique]
le ministre de l'intérieur l'avait
annoncé en juillet le lancement d'une
expérimentation de caméras individuel
pour les sapeurs pompiers du service
d'incendié et de secours
ce sont en tout porter candidat cette
phase de test dont le sdi 78 le
reportage de manon varaldo et de
mathilde et demi les sapeurs pompiers du
service d'incendié et de secours des
yvelines ont fait l'acquisition de 26
caméras piétons elles sont déployées
dans sept centres d'incendié et de
secours du département dont la caserne
de versailles ce dispositif expérimental
est une première dans les yvelines
il ya un certain nombre de
de territoire dans les yvelines où des
pompiers sont peut-être parfois
davantage victime de prises à partie
personnelle cette caméra piéton est un
outil de lutte et de prévention contre
les agressions de sapeurs pompiers en
intervention
elles ont augmenté de 2 113 % en dix ans
l'objectif c'est de ramener le calme de
dissuader d'éviter de se faire agresser
en en essayant de faire en sorte que
l'individu qui vous menace dont qui vous
agressent verbalement voir qui vous
agressent physiquement évite de le faire
du fait qu'il va savoir qui va être
filmé les images et sons seront
conservées pendant six mois les caméras
piéton d'une autonomie de 12 heures
seront portés par un membre d'équipage
qui pourra opérer au déclenchement sur
sa propre initiative
si maintenant la joie imprimé par erreur
à puis la caméra se déclenche pas par
contre lorsqu'il a pu deux fois c'est
pour confirmer concluant saison délicate
donc sa promo c'est très intéressant
ces caméras permettront la collecte de
preuves pour identifier et poursuivre
les auteurs de l'agression
mais aussi améliorer la formation des
agents par les captations pour certains
pompiers est là avant tout un rôle de
dissuasion
c'est quelque chose de rassurant pour
notre sécurité cette phase
d'expérimentation des caméras piétons
durera jusqu'en février 2022 a eu en
cours dans le quartier du pont du rotois
la première pierre symbolique de deux
nouvelles résidences a été posée hier
mardi en présence du maire de la commune
des promoteurs et architectes de la
structure ariane et cassiopée le nom de
ses deux résidences devraient être
livrés en 2021 elles comprendront à 63
logements en accession aidée du 2 au 5
pièces les réactions au micro de miquel
et demi d'euros ce projet est plutôt
pour les habitants de guyancourt
aujourd'hui il représente 38% des
réservataires le reste étant les
habitants de 2 me montigny 74% à
réserver on est au coulage des
fondations
donc c'est un très bon score deux
invités à présent avec moi en plateau
joseph hameau les ouchy et francine
charloton bonsoir ça vous êtes toutes
les deux de l'association d'elancourt
réveille toi qui a été créé il ya trois
ans maintenant vous voulez ce soir nous
parler d'une nouvelle action qui a été
lancée révèle toi pro qui a pour but
d'accompagner les femmes
saint-quentinoise vers l'insertion
professionnelle on va en parler dans un
instant d'abord votre association juste
pour rappeler ses missions elle
s'adresse aux familles monoparentales
les mamans les papas qui vivent seules
avec leurs enfants comment vous vous les
accompagnez comment ils sont aidés
justement on les reçoit notamment lors
de cafés débats ont fait mensuellement
donc un samedi par mois d'après midi
avec les parents qui viennent d'un côté
écouter un intervenant sur une
thématique qui a déjà été défini l
avance avec les adhérents et les enfants
pris en charge pour une activité qui est
musicale cette année l'année dernière a
été sportive avec du taekwondo et cette
année on va faire de la musique est
normalement une bonne surprise avant la
fin de l'année peut-être sur l'écriture
d'une chanson est donc une nouvelle
action lancée depuis un mois maintenant
révèle trois pros qui accompagne les
femmes éloignées de l'emploi qui vivent
à saint quentin en yvelines dans leur
parcours d'insertion professionnelle
cette fois-ci voilà pourquoi pourquoi
lancer cette action
on a débuté depuis juin 2018 à la cité
des métiers
une action qui s'appelle comment se
former vous travaillez en et de lancer à
son enfant parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte d'une chose c'est que la plupart
des familles monoparentales notamment
les femmes se retrouvent après la
séparation en rupture professionnelle
lors de ces ateliers nous sommes rendu
compte que ce sont les femmes qui
viennent le plus souvent en plus
qu'elles ne connaissent pas leurs droits
à la formation ni les besoins en emplois
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
donc on a proposé cette nouvelle action
pour pouvoir les accompagner sur un
temps de trois mois à raison de six
heures par semaine en collectif et 2h en
individuel pour pouvoir travailler avec
elles soient les besoins en emplois de
l'emploi pardon soir de l'opération mais
également sur leur réinsertion
professionnelle parce que beaucoup sont
éloignés de l'emploi depuis il ne serait
pas depuis deux trois ans
et puis retravailler avec elle tout ce
qui est cv et de lettres de motivation
confiance en soi
comment se présente mais et c'est donc
l'idée finalement elle est venue vous le
dites de votre expérience que vous avez
constaté au travers d'actions déjà mené
2 1 parce que ben beaucoup de familles
sont en rupture en effet son pendant le
temps de la séparation après la
séparation centré sur leurs
problématiques sur leurs enfants et les
parents s'oublie et notamment les femmes
souvent sont du coup dépendante
financièrement d'un conjoint d'un
ex-conjoint qu avec qui elle est en
conflit
donc ça les met dans une situation
vraiment particulièrement difficile et
l'idée c'est de se dire que pour réussir
à rebâtir sa famille à se reconstruire
il faut aussi professionnellement ceux
de se construire et on les amène par le
biais de ses cafés débats ou par ses
sorties à ré envisager de se projeter
dans le monde professionnel parce que de
toutes les façons leur indépendance et
une clé aussi pour pouvoir réussir donc
une action pour les femmes qui s'adresse
justement qui peut être bénéficiaires de
cette action les femmes en âge de
travailler de 16 à 65 ans les
cinquantièmes les femmes deux habitants
dans l'animation de saint quentin en
yvelines
alors pour être bien précises parce
qu'elles n'ont pas besoin d'être faye
monoparentales donc ça peut être des
femmes quel que soit ce statut
célibataire marié ou autre il faut
également que peuvent être statut rsa ou
pôle emploi quel que soit le statut même
si elles sont salariées par exemple un
mi temps voilà faut juste qu'elles
soient disponibles les mardis après midi
de 14 heures à 17 heures et les jeudis
après midi de 14 heures à 17 heures
également
et pendant trois mois donc là l'action a
commencé début novembre et se terminera
pour cette session le 14 février et la
prochaine session débutera le 24 février
et se terminera le 15 mai donc déjà des
bénéficiaires quels sont les premiers
retours vous peut avoir lors on est au
tout début de cette action mais ce qu'il
ya déjà des premiers retours constatés
tout à fait que les personnes qui se
sentent en tout cas entendue et prise en
compte
ça c'est vraiment le retour qu'on a
parce que bien souvent elles sont aussi
en rupture avec les institutions le pôle
emploi ou d'autres où sont dans des
situations où elles sont presque pas
accompagne à bhl sur un projet tangible
donc ils vos rêves réfléchir et
reprendre tout au début pour les amener
à ce a parlé aussi se libérer
leur angoisse etc et ensuite pouvoir
ensuite envisager de se projeter à
partir de soi personnellement parce
qu'on peut devenir professionnellement
parce qu'on a de la valeur je lui disais
je vous ai failli à une première phase
qui a débuté mon peut encore être
accompagné comment on fait justement
pour pour rejoindre cette action
téléphonie alors il ya les liens du site
internet et de votre page facebook qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran nous
rejoindre directement sa page facebook
par un message donc la personne ne
téléphonera mort à moi directement
il y aura un premier entretien nos
premiers entretiens ce sera pour
échanger cas personne voilà savoir ce
qu'elle connaît de l'action où elle en
est au niveau de sa vie professionnelle
on vous de l'idée qu'elle en a enfin où
le souhait professionnelle que la
personne a donc c'est un premier contact
comme ça et puis ensuite on l'inscrit
pour la prochaine session
si en plus ça personne est accompagné
par une intérieure sociale par le pôle
emploi par un autre dispositif emploi du
territoire c'est encore mieux parce que
nous ce qu'on veut c'est vraiment ouvrir
le champ et faire un accompagnement
enfin l'accompagnement et de l'eau balle
pour ces personnes éloignées de l'emploi
donc à nous seuls nous savons peu par
pour pas répondre pardon problématique
moi c'est vraiment ouvrir vers tous les
acteurs du territoire et toutes les
informations de rappel sur les liens qui
s'afficheront en bas de l'écran merci
joseph à moléson chi merci à francine
bouchard l'otan et d'être venu de parler
de cette action réveille toi pro c'est
l'un des derniers quartiers à être sorti
de terre à saint cyr l'école charles
renard a désormais une crèche depuis
début septembre les libellules une
structure municipale en délégation de
service avec la maison bleue elle
comprend plusieurs coins commun des
salles sensorielle de motricité de jeux
d'eau et des espaces moteur avec
notamment une grande structure en bois
14 personnes en tout il travaille à
temps plein une capacité qui s'appellera
qui s'élèvera à terme à 70 places
autre particularité des places sont
réservées pour des enfants porteurs de
handicap ou de maladies chroniques ainsi
que pour des enfants dont les parents
sont en insertion professionnelle les
propos recueillis par marylène iapichino
c'est un choix au niveau des relations
sociales de la vie
donc on va permettre aux familles soit
de souffler soit de pouvoir s'insérer
professionnellement et que le handicap
ou la situation de leur enfant ne les
empêche pas justement de pouvoir
poursuivre dans la joute professionnels
on a au total 1200 98 mètres carrés donc
une très très grande structure on a
quatre sections qui sont chacune
constituée de deux unités qui
communiquent les unes avec les autres
chaque unité en dortoir battement une
salle de bains communicante également
donc tout à disposition des
professionnels pour qu'elles puissent
intervenir auprès des enfants et les
accompagner en toute sérénité de façon
très confortable suite de nos focus sur
les personnalités yvelinoise de 2019
plus que l'année elle a marqué sa
discipline l'histoire de sa discipline
armel le bras chopard a été la première
femme agrégée en sciences politiques
elle a été lauréate notamment du prix
médicis en 2000 ancienne vice présidente
de l'ue vs cus ou portraits signés par
marylène iapichino dans ce bâtiment
leclerc historique de l'antenne
billancourt toise de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
armel le bras chopard ne compte plus les
souvenirs elle l'a vu se construire et
évoluer
et là le plus grand amphi du départ des
souvenirs qui tiennent dans ses journaux
réalisé par les étudiants promotion 1988
on y trouve cette anecdote de la fac
dans un couffin
le bâtiment était à l'origine une école
maternelle c'était drôle parce que les
les sièges étaient tout petits bouts de
l'étoile est 9 heures mais port quand
l'antenne devient uv est ce qu elle en
est le vice président elle impulse
également la création d'une filière
sciences politiques
alors qu'il en existait peu en france
mais dans la vie d'une universitaire il
ya aussi la recherche et les livres dont
classe et tous les livres une partie
parce que j'en ai encore en haut tout ce
qui concerne des deux ce qui concerne
les femmes
première femme à avoir obtenu
l'agrégation de sciences politiques elle
consacre sa thèse à pierre leroux
qu'elle considère comme l'inventeur du
socialisme j'ai feuilleté un manuel
d'histoire des idées politiques et la
page s'est arrêté à pierre l'euro et
alors je lis qu'on
l'auteur du manuel disait ce cet auteur
est complètement fou sa pensée
rocambolesque fera et je me suis dit
c'est pour moi
pierre leroux est aussi le premier
député à avoir parlé du droit de vote
pour les femmes à l'assemblée en 1848
les femmes et des inégalités de genre
traverse les travaux d'armel le bras
chopard des travaux qui lui valent des
reconnaissances pour le zoo des
philosophes
elle obtient le prix médicis catégorie
et c'est une surprise et alors j'avais
une nuée de journalistes autour de moi
alors comment qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'est
ce qu'est ce qu'il ya dans ce livre de
seth des rails je me souviens que
j'étais tellement abrutis que je vais
produit pas je ne sais pas après ce
livre elle se consacre pleinement à une
nouvelle mission
elle est appelée au ministère de
l'éducation nationale pour travailler
sur l'égalité des chances femmes hommes
dans l'enseignement supérieur depuis les
universités sont toutes dotées de chargé
de mission égalité femmes-hommes
ou comment transformer la théorie en
pratique avec ses livres elle espère
apporter sa petite contribution à une
prise de conscience plus générale et
c'est très difficile de faire comprendre
que le féminisme c'est pas la prise du
pouvoir par les femmes c'est la place
des femmes à égalité avec des hommes
le ministre cdh une idée de d'une
harmonieuse mixité si les bancs des
amphithéâtres lui manque
elle n'arrête pas l'écriture et la
recherche son dernier livre les
pérégrinations des compagnons de la
femme est sortie il ya quelques semaines
les recherches pour le prochain sont
déjà fait un retour sur pierre leroux et
sa lutte pour défendre le droit de vote
des femmes
samedi dernier le vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines s'est
métamorphosée en véritable temple de la
musique électronique avec la soirée en
bassa d'un rendez-vous 100% daube step
qui a réuni près de 2600 personnes
retour avec mélanie poké et aurélie ans
de la musique électro basé sur des
basses profondes et puissantes
les amateurs de dub step avait rendez
vous le 7 décembre au vélodrome
nationale pour la soirée ambassades
l'occasion de fêter les 10 ans du label
never say die le plus grand des labels
dubstep
en ce moment on y trouve absolument tous
les artistes du moment et aussi toutes
les grosses têtes d'affiché de la baisse
physique aujourd'hui encore
particulièrement du dubstep sans passer
par les mercis des violences et ces
bonne ambiance les gens qui viennent
sont cools ya du bon sommeil le système
sont quand même assez sympa il n'y pas
mal de basse de 21h à 6h du matin une
dizaine d'artistes se sont succédé sur
scène the boys space l'ices ou encore
hot prophète en raison des mouvements
sociaux certains dj n'ont pas pu être
présents ce qui n'a pas semblé gâcher le
plaisir des participants
c'est dommage mais ça vaut le coup ça
vaut le coup d'être là tout le monde est
sympa assez content de voir notre ami
bouddha qui l'a justement donc très
content de le voir pour la première fois
surtout à l'ambassade six mois de
préparation ont été nécessaires pour
mettre en place cette soirée au
vélodrome nationale ambitions du site
devenir un nouveau pôle de référence
pour les artistes
le rhum est une structure très
importante très conséquente
du coup les artistes les plus reconnus
et connu viendront encore et toujours y
sont l'événement a rassemblé de 1600
personnes
avant de parler des municipales le point
sur vos conditions de circulation demain
jeudi dans les transports plusieurs
syndicats ont appelés à renforcer la
grève contre le projet de réforme des
retraites non content d annonce
aujourd'hui du premier ministre edouard
philippe
les perturbations seront sensiblement
les mêmes qu'aujourd'hui le trafic est
de la ligne u qui a repris très
partiellement aujourd'hui sera encore
très perturbé demain prévoir toujours un
train par sens toutes les une à deux
heures entre 5h20 et 00h56 pour la ligne
n seul l'amplitude horaire change par
rapport à aujourd'hui un train toutes
les 30 minutes entre rambouillet paris
montparnasse de 5h30 à 10h30 et de 16h30
à 21h30 autres en autant de trains sur
l'axé plaisir grignon et mais sur les
créneaux 5h15 10h30 et 16h 15 22 heures
pour les lignes de rer peu ou pas de
changement non plus et un train sur deux
en heure de pointe sur le rer à un train
sur trois pour le rer b l'interconnexion
reste interrompue en gare du nord
enfin aucun train ne circulera encore
sur le rer c demain entre paris
austerlitz et les gares de saint quentin
en yvelines versailles rive gauche et
versailles chantiers
[Musique]
on termine ce journal par une page
dédiée aux élections municipales c'est
au programme les 15 et 22 mars prochains
cet écho de campagne d'abord à
mantes-la-ville seule commune est reine
de la région le parti socialiste et le
parti communiste appelle à une liste
unique pour faire face au maire
rassemblement national cyril note dans
un communiqué la firme pas d'ultimatum
est ni de leadership absolu mais le but
commun de redonner des droits un avenir
et un espoir au mans devillois fin de
citation précisons précisons que si un
temps une liste à droite gauche avait
été évoquée pour ce scrutin se sont bien
cinq listes en tout qui sont candidates
pour le moment face à cyril note le
maire sortant à la verrière pas d'union
de la gauche en vue dans ce bastion
communiste depuis les années 1970
onze élus de la majorité dont quatre
adjoints vont mener une liste face à la
maire sortante nelly duthu bonsoir jean
yves les bons soirs vous êtes le premier
adjoint de la commune de la verrière en
charge de l'éducation de la petite
enfance et vous serez la tête de liste
de cette candidature dit
art gauche ensemble là derrière
citoyenne début 2019 on rappelle le
contexte vous aviez créé votre propre
groupe au sein du conseil municipal
pourquoi partir divisés pour ce scrutin
c'est une question en effet pourquoi
partir divisés alors que tous nous nous
amener à être ensemble à écouter on a
été confronté à des différences avec
madame la maire qui n'a pas une écoute
comment dire tout à fait démocratique
républicaine et l'ancienne époque un
manque de concertation c'est ça on n'est
pas du tout dans le dans les changes le
décide sans concerter et donc à partir
de là
malgré nos différentes interventions des
uns et des autres pour le lui dire pour
dire tout et il faut changer de
stratégie être un peu plus ouverts à l
écoute de vos de vos adjoints
elle n'a pas tenu compte et donc à
partir de là
s'en est suivi toute une série de
décisions de la part des uns et des
autres qui nous ont conduit à constituer
un groupe en effet au sein de la
majorité qui par le passé il existait
aussi n'était pas une n'est pas une
nouveauté en soi même si la sensibilité
au fond est la même celle celle de
gauche c'est une sensibilité de gauche
bien évidemment oui oui puisque la liste
était de gauche complètement de gauche
d'ailleurs n'est pas un risque du coup
de voir
la verrière justement n'être plus une
commune de gauche c'est que c'est ma
paris finalement de se lancer
c'est ce qu'on vise c'est ce qu'on nous
dit c'est ce qu'on nous pousse à
entendre après après il ya un moment
donné où il faut prendre ses
responsabilités si vous voulez nous on a
considéré qu' au regard des projets qui
étaient posées sur la table sans
concertation et des décisions qui
étaient prises par rapport à ces projets
il fallait bien réagir et agir ça veut
dire aussi agir et donc on a agi après
on est aussi dans une démocratie et on a
aussi le droit je pense pour l'intérêt
des habitants de dire quand on a des
différences et ne pas avoir peur d'aller
face aux électeurs se présenter voilà et
des divergences notamment aux propos
d'un sujet 1 c'était la future crèche
qui doit être construit en lieu et place
de l'ancienne pmi du coup c'est là
c'était là juste conséquence de proposer
cette phase non non c'est pas c'est pas
la crèche au elle même parce que ce soit
la crève c'était l'un des sujets en tout
cas de divergence
sur les moyens oui mais pas sur
l'emplacement de la crèche et pas sur la
décision de la cre est ce parce que là
l'emplacement de moi je les propose il
ya bien longtemps je pensais que la pmi
et ont été retirés de notre ville à
notre grande peine si vous voulez c'est
quand même un outil qui était fort
apprécié de la population est donc cet
outil étant présents étant là il fallait
lui redonner une seconde vie
je pense que la crèche s'y prêtait bien
enfin l'idée de la crèche se prête bien
à ça en effet mais la divergence ne
porte pas c'était sur les financements
non portent elles portent plutôt sur le
projet d'ensemble sur sur la ville vous
avez on a porté un projet gare bekale
qui a été approuvé en communauté d'agglo
qui a été validé par le préfet et puis
bloquée depuis maintenant trois ans on
devrait normalement sortir de terre 300
logements là c'est ce qui était prévu
dans le programme mais du fait de la
décision de certains bain aujourd'hui il
n'en est rien puisque certains
d'ailleurs dans ces mêmes là s'en émeuve
mais bon juste avant de parler des
priorités parce que j'ai bien compris
que la guerre beckham c'était l'une des
priorités votre liste vous l'annoncer
comme une liste de gauche ouverte ça
veut dire vous vous revendiquez pas
spécialement d'investiture aujourd'hui
non c'est une liste de gauche ouverte et
sans investiture
sans appui de partie c'est pour être
c'est ça la question et c'est ça la
réponse est donc on veut nous venons en
aux priorités donc vous parler du projet
de garder calme ça projet d'ensemble si
vous voulez on a lancé les bécanes et
quand on a lancé les bécanes on s'est
dit aussi il fallait rire qu'il fallait
réfléchir autrement pour le reste de la
ville et donc on a aussi c'est vrai que
c'était pas dans le programme penser à
revoir le quartier du bois de l'étang en
l'inscrivant dans la rénovation urbaine
c'est aujourd'hui alors il n'est pas en
tout cas retenu dans l'anru ce quartier
témoin de temps vous avez une vision
différente par rapport à la maire
sortante vous souhaitez une une
dévolution plus qu une reconstruction
c'est ça on souhaite réaménager le
quartier qui comprendrait en effet des
démolitions on l'a écrit au préfet on a
été très clair là dessus on a été très
clair en conseil municipal
comme madame l'a fait la mère a fait
voter une motion dans ce sens là en
faisant venir le collectif d'ailleurs du
bois de l'étang
là dessus nous on a été très très très
sincère et on a dit le pourquoi et
pourrait si nécessaire par rapport à une
simple réhabilitation
si je peux dire parce que il faut
redonner de l'attractivité à la commune
et aussi à ce quartier qui se meurt
parce que on a une politique de logement
de la part de l'état qui paupérise le
quartier et qui ne le tire pas vers le
haut vous avez vu que le pisa dit dans
les enquêtes sur l'éducation nationale
peas a dit les différences qui s'opèrent
c'est pas tellement le niveau dépenses
des quais de notre population qui est
pas bonne c'est l'organisation et la
spatialisation des secteurs éducatif qui
sont à à revoir c'est ça qui est pas
tellement le niveau d'apprentissage de
de nos enfants donc à partir de là nous
on considère qu'il faut en effet
travaillé à ça de manière à tirer nos
enfants vers le haut oui parce que
aujourd'hui c'est comme ça que ça marche
d'autres sociétés fonctionnent à dessus
et ans l'un des sujets importants aussi
à la verrière où la population est
davantage jeunes c'est le chômage 16 %
de demandeurs d'emploi dans la commune
on est bien au dessus de la moyenne dans
les yvelines s'il ya une attention
particulière aux six mètres
alors l'autre auteur fait oui parce que
ce qui est terrible c'est qu'on a les
outils pour répondre à ça et qu'on s'en
sert pas bien il ya un potentiel
voilà mais allah derrière et sur le
territoire de 50 ha je rappelle qu'une
mission locale intercommunale
quand même donc c'est un outil en faveur
de la jeunesse dont on ne sait pas bien
il ya le pôle emploi il ya les centres
de formation si vous voulez les outils
sur le territoire il existe il se veut
dire ça évidemment le lien avec
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines faut il faut travailler là
dessus et et il faut arrêter de penser
que la commune peut à elle seule régler
le problème c'est pas possible ça il
faut en effet s'appuyer sur les
partenaires qui sont compétents qu'ils
savent faire et puis et puis c'est tout
voilà les autres priorités l on parle de
plusieurs projets le réaménagement du
carrefour de la manne budden qui
concerne la commune de la verrière ça
c'est un sujet à suivre aussi c'est le
désenclavement rappelleront il ya eu
deux réunions qui se sont tenues dont
sur lesquels j'ai participé sur lequel
j'ai dit un certain nombre de choses on
est ce carrefour va permettre en effet
de désenclaver la ville mais en même
temps si on ne fait rien sur le passage
souterrain qui ouvre sur la sur la ville
je crains fort que
on soit un bété dans les années qui
viennent donc je propose que là on
regarde d'un peu plus près cette
situation là tout comme on pourrait
regarder une ouverture vers la route de
de coignières allant vers le minime pour
rejoindre le carrefour de la marque à
lyon pas de la mare c'est pas de ma
sacoche
en tout cas c'est le des fontaines
pardon franklin oil j'ai cherché à
obtenir fourgue une dernière question ce
qu'on arrive à la fin de cet entretien
sur la participation elle était aux
alentours de 54 % à la verrière en 2014
comment mobiliser les électeurs en
allant les voir tout simplement en
allant porter le projet en porte à porte
en expliquant en rassurant en rappelant
qu' ils sont aussi des stickers de leur
avenir et que c'est important pour eux
que d'aller dire dans les urnes ne le
choix qu'ils souhaiteraient voir naître
pour les six ans qui viennent après vos
prochains rendez vous est ce que vous
avez des meetings des réunions publiques
sont une réunion publique demain soir
sur le l'aménagement du territoire et
l'écologie sur la question
environnementale
on en a une autre le 18 décembre la plus
tôt sur le handicap la santé
et puis
les anciens et puis pour le moment voilà
merci jean yves blais je rappelle que
vous êtes la tête de liste de donc la
liste ensemble la verrière citoyenne et
je précise que dans la commune la maire
sortante nelly duthu est également
candidate
tout comme le conseiller municipal
d'opposition de droite nicola dainville
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi et belle soirée à tous
sur tv 78
[Musique]
non